Générique
...
-La robotique est aujourd'hui
partout. Elle s'est aussi
répandue au sein des armées,
dans tous les milieux.
A côté des drones
aériens, les robots terrestres
et sous-marins se développent,
et pour des missions
très variées,
du soutien à la logistique,
de l'observation
à la détection,
de la surveillance
à l'appui au combat.
-Les robots sont un game changer.
Ils vont permettre
de changer l'art
de faire la guerre.
-La robotique devrait permettre
d'éloigner l'homme de la menace
et aussi de démultiplier
ses capacités.
-La vraie question
aujourd'hui :
est-ce une évolution ou est-ce
que ce sera une révolution ?
-La robotisation des armées
est en marche,
mais jusqu'où ira-t-elle ?
A quoi ressemblera
le champ de bataille de demain ?
Moins d'humains et plus de robots.
La guerre finira-t-elle
par être menée
par des machines ?
Autant de bouleversements
qui posent question.
-Pour nous,
point de salut sans part
de l'humain dans la décision.
-Il y a des questions éthiques
abyssales qui se posent.
-En intervention,
les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
sont souvent épaulés
par Colossus,
un collègue
un peu particulier.
Un robot d'extinction employé dans
des conditions parfois extrêmes,
avec un objectif : éloigner l'homme
du danger. Le tout 1er exemplaire
entre en service en 2017
à Issy-les-Moulineaux,
l'un des 3 centres
de secours spécialisés
dans l'exploration longue durée.
-Le principal intérêt des robots
est d'envoyer le robot
en cas de risque d'effondrement,
d'éboulement ou de grosse chaleur,
où le sapeur-pompier serait
beaucoup trop exposé à un risque,
en espérant éviter
des morts par la suite.
Aujourd'hui,
ce robot est indispensable
dans notre manière d'intervenir.
On pourrait
difficilement
revenir en arrière.
C'est un matériel
qui a fait ses preuves.
-A raison de 65 départs
en intervention par an en moyenne,
le robot est régulièrement engagé
sur des incendies.
C'est aussi un engin
de reconnaissance. Avec
ses capteurs, il voit à 360 degrés
de jour comme de nuit et détecte
les gaz et produits toxiques.
Cette machine
est également adaptée
au transport de victimes
et de matériel.
-Ca représente
une charge énorme.
On est sur presque
plus de 200 kilos à porter,
donc répartis
sur les personnels bien sûr.
Mais à côté de ça,
s'ils portent 200 kilos
sur des longues distances,
automatiquement,
ils sont plus fatigués
pour commencer leur mission.
C'est pour préserver le pompier,
pour être fort dans l'action
à l'instant T.
-Le robot pour être plus fort,
mais aussi plus rapide.
-Le robot, on met
1 minute
pour le sortir de l'engin
et les engins
comme les premiers intervenants
sont déjà garés.
On se retrouve
avec des rues bloquées.
Notre matériel est sur le robot,
on peut monter sur le trottoir
et aller rapidement
sur les lieux de l'intervention
et s'engager au plus vite.
Le facteur temps est important.
-La robotique terrestre
au service du combattant,
une histoire qui date.
Au 20e siècle déjà,
des ingénieurs français conçoivent
des machines comme cette torpille
destinée à transporter
des explosifs
dans les tranchées ennemies
à l'époque de la Grande Guerre
avec plus ou moins de succès.
Parmi les plus aboutis,
le Goliath,
fabriqué par les Allemands
au cours
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Explosion
La robotique s'est
peu à peu développée
en parallèle
des conflits armés.
-Le 11 septembre 2011,
l'Amérique est foudroyée
par les attentats
du World Trade Center.
Le pays le plus puissant du monde
se voit ainsi fragilisé
par le terrorisme.
-Un des éléments marquants
de l'introduction des robots
dans les armées,
ce sont les guerres
en Irak et en Afghanistan
du début du 21e siècle,
avec notamment l'apparition
chez les insurgés
d'engins explosifs improvisés.
Et ces engins explosifs improvisés,
laissés sur le bord
de la route,
qui explosaient
au passage d'une unité
militaire amie,
ont causé énormément de dégâts
aux forces de la coalition,
notamment
les militaires français.
Presque un sur deux
malheureusement
dans ces conflits a été tué
ou blessé par ces engins.
Il a fallu trouver
des solutions
et celle qui est apparue
naturellement
est le robot,
qui permet de se déporter,
de se déplacer
et d'aller voir
une menace potentielle,
d'aller creuser le sol,
prendre des photos,
analyser les images
et détecter s'il y avait
un engin explosif improvisé
sur le bord de la route.
-Dans les armées,
les démineurs sont considérés
comme les précurseurs
de l'utilisation
de robots terrestres.
Parmi eux, le capitaine Florent.
En près de 40 ans
de carrière,
il a participé à beaucoup
d'opérations,
En ex-République yougoslave
de Macédoine avec le 17e régiment
du génie parachutiste,
comme le montrent
ces images tournées en 1999,
mais aussi au Cambodge, en Bosnie,
au Liban et au Kosovo,
en Afghanistan,
en Irak et en Syrie,
et plus récemment au Mali.
-Les premiers IED sérieux
sur lesquels j'ai été confronté,
c'est en Afghanistan,
où là, vraiment,
la technologie et les techniques
utilisées par l'ennemi
étaient vraiment
de très haut niveau.
-Il forme désormais
les jeunes démineurs,
toutes armées confondues,
au désamorçage et à l'élimination
d'engins explosifs
industriels ou artisanaux,
ainsi qu'à l'emploi des robots
de déminage comme celui-ci.
-C'est un robot
qu'on a eu à l'époque
de l'Afghanistan,
donc le combat de contact,
il nous fallait un robot léger,
maniable, rapide,
qui puisse intervenir au profit
des démineurs, de l'infanterie
et de la main-d'oeuvre
lors d'une embuscade.
Nous avons également
un robot plus lourd
qui permettra d'autres types
d'intervention, que ce soit
sur le territoire national
ou en extérieur.
-Un outil dont il ne peut plus
se séparer.
-Je suis devenu addict
à ces 2 engins.
Parce que, dans l'équipe,
le robot,
c'est lui qui va
y aller en premier.
C'est la 1re question
que je me pose face à une menace
comme ici, par exemple.
La 1re question
que je me pose, c'est :
le robot peut-il y aller
à ma place ?
C'est son boulot,
nous, on a le nôtre.
S'il peut pas y aller,
pour des raisons diverses
et variées, du genre
accessibilité, dangerosité
de tirs directs,
par exemple,
ou tout simplement
l'approche est difficile
puisqu'il y a des fils pièges.
Le robot peut pas
neutraliser un fil piège.
Donc là, effectivement,
on va y aller.
Mais tout d'abord, c'est lui.
S'il ne peut pas,
on ne le met pas de côté,
on l'utilise quand même
pour porter du matériel.
Soit il se met en position
pour nous filmer
et qu'on soit en connexion directe
avec notre équipier
qui reste au niveau
du véhicule blindé ou du camion.
Le robot et nos démineurs,
c'est un tout.
Il fait partie de l'équipe.
-Depuis 20 ans, les robots du génie
ont largement évolué.
Aujourd'hui,
une nouvelle génération fait
son apparition,
plus agile
et embarquant
davantage de technologie.
-Comme les engins explosifs
ne cessent de se diversifier,
il faut utiliser
des capteurs
là aussi diversifiés
pour maximiser les chances
de les détecter.
Et donc, on peut avoir,
par exemple,
des capteurs qui vont détecter
plutôt l'électronique,
des changements dans le sol.
Et on cherche même à fusionner
les informations qui proviennent
des différents capteurs.
-C'est l'exemple du RSM,
de l'entreprise nantaise Capacités,
soutenue par l'Agence
de l'Innovation de Défense,
un robot de détection de mine
antipersonnel
à faible signature magnétique,
dont l'utilité sera
tant militaire
en temps de conflit
que civile pour restituer
des terrains sécurisés
aux populations.
-Nous avons proposé
d'associer de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la robotique
dans une interface de collaboration
avec les démineurs.
Cette interface permet
d'analyser les données recueillies
par le robot et d'aider
le démineur à prendre des décisions
à distance et en sécurité.
Aujourd'hui, on a
une évolution de la philosophie
de l'autonomie
dans la robotique.
On a longtemps cru
qu'on allait mettre des robots
à la place des hommes.
Aujourd'hui, il s'agit surtout
de mettre des robots
avec les hommes
et de pouvoir les faire collaborer.
Donc c'est un robot
et un homme plus qu'un robot
à la place de l'homme.
-Ce robot utilise
plusieurs techniques :
de la mesure de contact,
de la mesure
sans contact
et du radar de sol.
Les données recueillies
sont stockées
et géolocalisées puis analysées.
Pour l'instant,
aucun système ne permet d'avoir
cette approche, mixant
ces différentes technologies.
-Donc le robot
peut travailler
sur des sous-munitions
qui arrivent par voie aérienne.
Ces sous-munitions
sont posées au sol,
peuvent être légèrement
dissimulées sous du feuillage,
et là, le robot peut
avancer de lui-même.
Par analyse d'image,
il va détecter
la sous-munition qui est présente
et s'arrêter
de lui-même
pour prévenir à distance.
-Le robot sait aussi détecter
les mines enterrées
et les dissocier
des objets naturels.
Il sonde le sol
en toute autonomie, libérant
le démineur
des tâches répétitives,
pénibles et dangereuses.
En mer, même combat.
Chaque année,
plus de 2000 munitions
sont détruites
par les plongeurs démineurs.
Dans cette guerre,
la marine nationale
elle aussi mise
sur la robotique
pour renouveler
et moderniser ses capacités.
C'est l'objectif du SLAM-F,
le 1er programme de drone naval
pour la France,
développé en coopération
avec la Grande-Bretagne.
-Alors, Fabien,
Frédéric, cette exploitation
de mission, ça donne quoi ?
-On est en train de regarder
la dernière mission qu'on a faite,
des rails
d'un demi-mille nautique
de longueur
et 300 mètres de fauché.
-Le but de la mine,
c'est d'interdire
le passage maritime, l'accès
à un port, l'accès à un détroit.
Et le système de lutte
contre les mines,
c'est le bouclier
contre cette menace.
Les mines deviennent
de plus en plus intelligentes,
de plus en plus furtives,
la menace évolue.
-Plusieurs pistes
ont été explorées
par la Direction générale
de l'Armement
avec les industriels.
Certaines ont été retenues,
d'autres non.
-Typiquement,
pour la neutralisation,
on avait imaginé
un drone kamikaze,
ce choix n'a pas été fait
pour le SLAM-F.
-Pour quelle raison ?
-L'idée, c'est quand même,
même si on veut éloigner
l'homme de la menace,
c'est important de garder l'homme
dans la boucle en permanence
et pour les fonctions
identification
et neutralisation de mine,
le choix d'un ROV,
donc un robot filoguidé,
piloté par le marin,
à distance, a été fait.
-Le prototype
qui préfigure le système final
est aujourd'hui
en cours d'évaluation
opérationnelle
par la marine nationale,
avec un objectif :
vérifier s'il répond bien
aux besoins et identifier
les ajustements éventuels
avant livraison
des premiers de série en 2024.
-Bonjour.
-Mes respects, commandant.
-On a fait un choix
de prendre un drone de surface
habitable.
Pendant la phase d'évaluation,
j'ai toujours du personnel à bord,
en cas de problème,
on peut reprendre la main
et mettre en oeuvre en local.
A terme,
mon opérateur sera en fait
à une dizaine de nautiques
de mon centre d'opérations
en train de piloter le drone.
Il y a 2 configurations,
une avec un sonar remorqué.
Il tiendra mieux
le courant que l'UV
et surtout j'aurai
une transmission
de mes données sonar
en direct vers mon centre.
L'opérateur pourra
vérifier la qualité de l'image
et si le fond n'est pas encombré,
identifier immédiatement
des contacts intéressants.
La 2e configuration est avec
le drone d'intervention sous-marin,
donc un robot,
qui permettra d'aller identifier
et si l'objet est une mine
de le contre-miner
en déposant une charge explosive
à proximité.
-A cela s'ajoutent 2 drones
sous-marins autonomes capables
de fournir des images sonar
de haute résolution et multi-angles.
-L'idée, aujourd'hui, c'est
que vous les utilisiez,
manipuliez
et que vous puissiez restituer
aux industriels qui sont là
votre perception de leur usage.
Et pour vous d'imaginer
ce que sera le combat de demain.
On a fait un exercice
ici à l'académie militaire
de Saint-Cyr Coëtquidan
avec l'école militaire interarmes
en 2021 en utilisant des robots
terrestres en combat urbain.
Et ces robots, ils avaient
une finalité,
c'est prendre du renseignement.
S'exposer,
détecter l'ennemi,
avant que l'ennemi
ne vous détecte.
On a fait des mesures
avec les élèves
officiers de l'intérêt
d'utiliser ces robots.
Est-ce que ça apporte
une plus-value opérationnelle ?
Des coups de feu retentissent.
-OK, go !
...
-C'est un peu plus long en termes
de délai pour la même manoeuvre.
On a 10, 15 minutes de plus.
Par contre, il y a pas de morts.
-Et l'ennemi a été identifié
en avance de phase
quasiment à chaque fois.
C'est le côté positif.
-Déjà bouclier
contre le danger,
le robot pourrait bientôt
avoir sa place
au combat pour voir, écouter,
sentir et agir plus loin.
-On s'y intéresse
pour l'infanterie, par exemple,
pour réaliser des investigations
de bâtiments, voir s'il y a
des présences ennemies
à l'intérieur, voire des pièges.
On envisage de l'utiliser
pour la reconnaissance,
la surveillance, également
peut-être
pour le ravitaillement
et pour l'appui au combat
également.
Ce qui paraît intéressant,
c'est de pouvoir exploiter
les capacités complémentaires
de l'homme et de la machine.
-C'est l'ambition du projet Vulcain,
porté par l'état-major
de l'armée de terre.
-Dans la multitude
des choses qu'on peut faire
au travers du prisme des robots
et de l'automatisation,
le champ des possibles
est si vaste
qu'il a fallu mettre en place
une démarche, une méthode.
C'est ça, le projet Vulcain.
C'est à l'horizon 2040 de disposer
d'unités opérationnelles
qui utilisent
et maîtrisent l'emploi
de systèmes automatisés
dans le combat de demain.
-Ambition incarnée par
la nouvelle section exploratoire
robotique, créée à l'été 2021
et qui rassemble aujourd'hui
17 militaires.
-L'utilisation des drones
et robots
change la façon de penser
au niveau de la manoeuvre.
Les missions qui se faisaient
en 1 heure se font en 10 minutes.
L'utilisation des drones en avance
de phase pour le renseignement
nous permet d'éviter certaines
missions et d'anticiper aussi.
-En fait, pour bien spécifier
les futurs robots,
les ingénieurs, notamment à la DGA,
ont besoin d'orientations
et de retours d'expérience
de la part des opérationnels.
Inversement, pour orienter
les futurs systèmes,
les opérationnels ont besoin
de tester des robots suffisamment
matures et proches
de leurs besoins.
Donc je pense que Vulcain
doit permettre de créer
les conditions
d'une boucle vertueuse
entre la recherche
et technologie,
les acquisitions
et le retour d'expérience
opérationnel.
-Historiquement, quand on faisait
des expérimentations,
on s'appuyait sur des unités
qui n'avaient pas
le même ressenti, la même approche
de ces systèmes automatisés.
Avoir un point fixe
avec des gens qui ne sont pas
des expérimentateurs,
mais bien des opérationnels
spécialisés dans l'usage
des robots, nous permet de comparer
les différents systèmes,
de les rendre compatibles
avec la difficulté du combat
sur le terrain.
-Bravo pour moi.
J'ai effectué
la reconnaissance
du rez-de-chaussée avec le SRMO,
dans la pièce de gauche,
j'ai un ennemi neutralisé.
Je demande l'autorisation
de pénétrer dans le bâtiment.
-La section teste
des robots aéroterrestres
dans des scénarios tactiques,
défensifs
comme offensifs, comme
ces mini-robots de reconnaissance
obtenus dans le cadre
du programme Scorpion,
qui renouvelle les équipements
de l'armée de terre.
-OK. Un ennemi détruit.
Pièce claire !
-Rattachée
au 94e régiment d'infanterie,
la section est localisée à Sissonne
dans l'Aisne, au centre
d'entraînement aux actions
en zone urbaine. Ce camp
dispose d'infrastructures
particulièrement adaptées
à l'usage de robots.
-En ville, on a une vision
assez restreinte
et on a des portes successives
dans des bâtiments
où les risques
d'avoir un piégeage
ou des ennemis cachés derrière
sont très fréquents.
L'emploi des robots
a tout son intérêt.
Dans les souterrains,
de la même manière,
on y voit très mal.
Il y a des labyrinthes
de tunnels où il peut,
là aussi, y avoir
beaucoup de piégeages,
d'ennemis cachés
et donc là également,
les robots peuvent amener
une plus-value intéressante
en évitant
des pertes humaines.
-Personnel ennemi armé
détecté.
-Historiquement, la ville
a toujours été un point dur
pour les combats
avec des rapports de force
toujours très importants.
La question que pose
le projet Vulcain est :
demain, les systèmes automatisés
permettront-ils
de réduire ce rapport de force
grâce à l'apport
de la robotique ?
-Pour y arriver,
des verrous technologiques
restent à surmonter,
comme de rendre le robot
autonome dans ses décisions
pour les déplacements.
-Un des défis
que doivent relever les industriels
est de permettre à ces machines
d'avoir une autonomie
pour libérer
le militaire,
notamment le déplacement.
C'est-à-dire pouvoir
donner à une machine
un ordre de déplacement
qu'il puisse exécuter
par lui-même.
C'est relativement aisé
dans les milieux homogènes
que sont les milieux
aériens et sous-marins,
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
sur le milieu terrestre.
-Le milieu terrestre cumule
de très nombreuses difficultés
pour la robotique terrestre.
On a une grande diversité
de l'environnement,
des scènes parfois changeantes,
très dynamiques. On a aussi
des zones qui sont
souvent compartimentées
délimitées
par des obstacles naturels,
artificiels.
Et ces caractéristiques impactent
très fortement
les capacités de mobilité,
les capacités de communication,
de réception des signaux
satellites pour la géolocalisation
ou encore le traitement d'images.
L'autonomie décisionnelle
est vraiment très importante
pour la robotique et pour pouvoir
aller vers une diversification
des applications. Ca permet
en fait d'éviter, par exemple,
à l'opérateur
de devoir se focaliser
sur la téléopération
d'un robot.
Ca permet de favoriser
la discrétion hertzienne.
Ca permet également
d'être beaucoup plus fluide
pour réagir aux aléas
dans l'environnement.
Idéalement, on aimerait même aller
jusqu'à des interactions
en langage naturel
comme on dit,
donc être capable
de dire au robot :
"Va te poster sur la colline
en te déplaçant
"de façon furtive."
-Un gros point positif
que j'ai vraiment apprécié
en position défensive,
en fait,
on avait décelé l'ennemi
peut-être deux fois plus vite
que sans les systèmes optiques.
A un moment,
on s'est retrouvés bloqués,
les robots les voyaient,
mais à l'oeil nu,
on voyait pas l'ennemi.
Au niveau tactique,
en défensif,
ça peut être vraiment
une grosse plus-value.
-Avec ces capacités,
le robot pourrait être
un pion tactique supplémentaire
dans la manoeuvre.
-Pion tactique pour le chef
militaire, c'est également
avoir la possibilité
d'utiliser
plusieurs robots en même temps,
des robots terrestres,
mais aussi aériens.
On peut coordonner
divers systèmes,
combattre
de façon collaborative.
-Alors, le combat collaboratif,
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est l'autre révolution,
l'autre game changer
qu'on identifie
pour le combat de demain.
L'idée est d'exploiter
la mise en réseau
de l'ensemble des plateformes
sur le champ de bataille
et d'optimiser leur coordination
pour accélérer
notamment le tempo
de la manoeuvre.
L'objectif,
c'est de comprendre, de décider
et d'agir plus vite
que l'adversaire
sur le terrain.
-La robotisation porte en elle
un potentiel révolutionnaire
pour les armées et autant
d'enjeux éthiques
et juridiques.
-La question de fond,
c'est la question du sens
de l'action militaire.
Ce sens ne peut être porté
que par l'homme,
que par le chef militaire.
Jamais une machine n'aura conscience
de ce qu'elle fait.
Elle n'est pas un agent moral.
-Vous savez, quand vous commandez
des hommes au combat,
une chose primordiale
est de donner du sens à leur action,
qu'ils comprennent ce qu'ils font,
pourquoi ils le font,
pourquoi ils voient
tout le monde
se faire "trouer la peau",
car ça arrive.
Pour tout, pour l'idée
qu'ils se font
de leur pays, de la patrie,
de leur drapeau,
du camarade à leurs côtés.
Tout ça,
un robot ne l'intègre pas.
Un robot ne l'intègre pas.
-En 2020,
une structure unique au monde
est créée
au ministère des Armées,
le 1er Comité d'éthique
de la Défense,
dont les travaux doivent
guider la conception,
le développement et l'utilisation
des systèmes d'armes.
En matière de robotique,
le Comité s'est penché
sur la question des SALA,
systèmes d'armes
létaux autonomes,
approuvant le choix de la France
d'y renoncer.
-Imaginons
qu'on arrive à faire
ce genre de systèmes,
coder des fonctions décisionnelles
évitant l'intervention
de l'être humain
dans l'appréciation de la situation
et dans l'enchaînement
avec la décision,
il faudra se poser la question
de ce qu'on est
en train de faire.
Doit-on le faire
et au nom de quoi ?
-Au Tchad,
dans une autre vie,
où, commandant à la tête
de mon régiment,
j'ai eu à tête reposée
aux rebelles du moment.
Ces rebelles avaient
les mêmes matériels
que l'armée nationale
aux côtés de laquelle
nous étions engagés.
De nuit, on a vu arriver
dans nos caméras
de vision nocturne
des véhicules identiques
à ceux de l'armée
avec laquelle nous étions,
progressant vers nous
avec des affûts de canon devant,
très dangereux.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Est-ce un ennemi,
est-ce qu'on le détruit ?
Est-ce un ami ?
Pas de liaison radio, etc.
Je n'ai pas tiré.
J'ai attendu le dernier moment
et fort heureusement,
parce que c'était des éléments
de l'armée
avec laquelle nous combattions
à l'époque.
Un SALA
aurait évidemment tiré.
-Si le système
est mal employé, etc.,
qui est responsable,
finalement ?
Est-ce que c'est
effectivement
le militaire
qui a pris la décision
d'utiliser ce système peut-être pas
dans les bonnes conditions ?
Est-ce que ce sont les concepteurs
du système qui sont en cause ?
Est-ce que ce sont les chercheurs
qui sont en cause ?
Qui est responsable ?
Il y a une sorte de dilution
de la responsabilité
qui va se produire.
-En France en tout cas,
la ligne de conduite est claire :
l'humain est aux commandes
de tout système d'arme,
ce qui ne signifie pas renoncer
à la recherche dans le domaine.
-Nous ne pouvons pas cesser
les études
poussant jusqu'au bout
la connaissance de ces armes.
Nos soldats,
nos marins doivent
pouvoir se prémunir
contre ces SALA
utilisés par d'autres.
Etant entendu que les organisations
terroristes se fichent
du tiers
comme du quart de l'éthique
et n'hésiteront pas
à acheter sur étagère
des armes qui pourraient être
des formes de SALA
et auxquelles
nous aurions à être confrontés.
-Alors, non seulement
les réflexions éthiques
sont prises en compte,
mais ça a été l'accélérateur
de la réflexion sur ce sujet.
Ca nous permet d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles
sur ce qui est réalisable ou non,
avec la notion de préserver
la responsabilité
du chef militaire
dans les ordres donnés,
exécutés
par une unité humaine
ou, demain, robotisée.
-L'apparition
des robots armés ou non,
téléopérés ou intégrant
de l'autonomie
bouleverse la pratique de la guerre.
Demain, ces machines seront
autant d'outils tactiques
que d'équipiers
sur le champ de bataille
comme peut-être un nouvel ennemi
à combattre.
Si des défis restent à relever,
comme les autres pays, la France
se prépare à cette mutation
en gardant à l'esprit
les mots de l'écrivain Rabelais :
"Science sans conscience
n'est que ruine de l'âme."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA